it's an art form that's over 5,000 years
old it's used to Enlighten or to welcome
Hindu gods to the
household a folk art passed down from
one generation to another and they can
take hours to
complete
the word Rangoli comes from the Sanskrit
word rang meaning color designs can be
made with materials like powdered
Limestone red okra colored sand flower
petals even colored
rocks
in Rangoli design you'll typically see
either geometric or flower and animal
motifs but Swami's use of Arabic designs
adds a level of intricacy that's
difficult to emulate and something all
his own and traditionally the designs
are small made outside the front door of
a home but Swami changed that too he
went big
toal
record last
mon
one time of year in particular Rangoli
can be seen outside of many households
across India this is Dali Dali
represents the Triumph of good over evil
light over darkness and wisdom over
ignorance these designs are part of a
cultural tradition to welcome lxmi the
goddess of wealth and good luck but
they're also an expression of Beauty for
others to
[Music]
see
for